all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up with the
mask technically it's the match volume 2
the mask returns but this basically
gives us
pretty much the closest thing we get to
an origin for where the mask
came from which is actually really cool
but uh in the event so
if you guys remember in the last video
that we did there was a point where
callaway
had the mask on and took out a whole
bunch of guys at an eatery and so the
results of this is that when those guys
were taken out what ended up happening
is you had this guy named don muzzo who
basically wanted to take out callaway
and so he ended up hiring a whole bunch
of these guys
and then sent them over to kelloway's
house in order to take him out now when
he gets there one of the things to keep
in mind
about calloway is he had basically
gotten rid of the mask he had
essentially buried it in his basement
and the hope was that he would never
have to use it again right because he
just deemed it as being too extreme too
dangerous for anybody
to be in possession of of course once
these guys get into his house and
basically start shooting the place up
then callaway immediately b-lines for
the basement right and and
almost gets to the point where he gets
the mask but then he gets shot up
and what this does is it basically leads
to all these guys uh really these three
guys snatching up the mask
and then heading to the getaway car
where they end up running into or really
kind of being driven away by
what is essentially a flunky right this
guy's just kind of like no i wouldn't
really say like a loser or a nobody but
he's kind of depicted to us that way but
the mask seemed to be of something
valuable right which seemed to be the
reason why kelloway was going for it
remember one of the things that that's
kind of important here
is no one really knows exactly how big
head works right the only people who are
really aware of that are like lionel who
was callaway's partner callaway
and uh and kathy and that's basically it
right stanley ipkis knew as well but
stanley ipkis is dead and so
because of that these guys don't know
that when you put the mask on
that you become bighead right big head
is kind of thought to be this guy who's
out there at one point is more or less
just vanished right and so as soon as
they take the mask and they put it on
this flunky who's driving the car he
immediately turns in a big head right
and then from there takes these guys out
in a car crash right now a lot of this
is due to the fact that as a flunky he
really doesn't get any respect from
anybody and part of this is because of
the fact that when it comes to any real
facet of life you got to earn respect
right i mean you know in this world all
you ever really owed is a little bit of
respect and a little bit of decency
everything else you earned the kind of
respect he's looking for you got to work
your way up the ranks right i mean it's
just it's kind of the nature of things
right middle school
high school the workforce the whole nine
yards life in general
you got to work your way up to getting
that kind of level of respect and so
because of that
in a lot of ways it's kind of vengeance
and it's also him kind of being like
okay like it's my time now right like i
can basically do anything and so these
guys basically
he kind of crashes the vehicle and then
just kind of starts cracking the kind of
jokes you normally expect from big head
right like he literally frames the shot
with his hands and he's like and there's
an ad for seat belts
but he kind of comes to this realization
that he's basically invulnerable now at
this point switch over to walter now
walter again kind of a reminder here is
basically a henchman right this is and
when i say henchmen he's like the
henchman right like this guy he never
talks and he's enormous right and he's
just he's muscle clad he's one of these
guys that you just don't mess with you
leave him a wide berth and you let him
do his own thing and so there's one guy
who kind of looks at him and he's like
he's like what the hell are you staring
at me for and walter's just like
just like takes this guy out right which
is i understand it prison life isn't
really all that different from high
school life you've got to go in there
and immediately let people know that
you're not somebody to mess with
otherwise people are just going to bust
your balls the whole time they're going
to give you a hard time right so you got
to make sure that the people who are
giving you a hard time come to an
understanding
that you are not the person to be given
a hard time and anybody who's
considering that will not do it either
right so basically make an example out
of the people who bully you and so
because of that
one of the things that happens is like
this guy goes crashing into a table
right and then this other guy stands up
and like who the hell did that
somebody's like he did johnny like he's
the one who did it and then this guy
realizes this walter and he's like oh
uh hey walter how's it going man and
it's just kind of like huh
you know just leave him alone
that's really kind of what happens here
right and so following that you
basically end up switching over to one
of the guys
who goes to the boss right you know
essentially looking up don muzzo and it
turns out one of these guys in the car
crash
actually survived the whole thing and so
when he's kind of like i want to talk to
don muzzo right this guy's like i mean
you know don muzzo is in miami right
like he's not here he took off to miami
to kind of lay low right avoid all this
different heat and so this guy who
survived the crash starts freaking out
and then screams right because he can't
believe this guy's in miami only for his
face to tear and for us to find out it's
the mask
that is basically big head right and so
this guy's like okay if the boss is in
miami then i'm the one running the show
now now here's one of the things to
understand about the criminal underbelly
right and i only know this from people i
know who work in like criminal justice
right like i've got a buddy who works in
the fbi and one of the things to know
about this is as i understand it
it really is just an opportunistic
setting when you have a situation where
somebody is kind of a dude in charge or
a woman in charge
and they either go missing or they die
it creates a power vacuum and people
just want to start sucking up right they
just immediately want to start taking
over that space and that's exactly what
this guy does right he's like if the
boss is gone then i'm the one who takes
over and there's enough
knowledge about big head out there that
no one really challenges him
right because every attempt that's been
made to kill big head whether he's been
shot up by cops or whatever
it never works right so people are kind
of like okay big head's here big head
says he's the boss i mean we can't kill
him
right i mean the guy's basically
invulnerable okay then we'll just go
ahead and leave it at that one of the
other things that he talks about
right big head's kind of like okay we're
going to expand our operation here right
like we're going to expand
in a big way and this of course runs
into turf wars and that's one of the
things that kind of goes on
is that when you have organized crime
things are kind of divvied up right
they're sort of split up you do run into
turf wars pretty consistently but it's
one of the big differences between like
you know your street level gang crime
and like organized crime right organized
crime also kind of has its namesake
because it has like legitimate
legitimate business fronts and things
like that but it's basically
you know a criminal enterprise that by
all standards of measurement acts like
a like an incorporated or a
corporation-based entity right they run
like a company and so what you basically
ended up running into here in ed city is
you had like
sections of the city that were kind of
carved out right so one crime group owns
this part of the city another crime
group owns that part of the city and
it's one of those like you stay away we
stay away kind of things right so like
everybody has their own little section
by going through and saying like we're
going to expand our territory they're
getting into turf wars and so whether
the question is asked like are you do
you really want to start a conflict with
all these gangs big head's response is
let me be the one to take care of it
right like i will handle all this stuff
and so what you end up doing is you
switch over to a guy named named
giuseppe right giuseppe prescotto and
this guy's kind of hosting a great big
huge event right kind of a party and so
this older woman is kind of like all
right everybody time for a family
portrait right because i guess family is
a really big thing for the mob and so
like
under the under the thing it's like okay
like everybody smile and then it turns
out to be big head and he's like and say
deceased and like sets off this bomb
it kills everybody in the area and then
you have this kind of coming together
of this uh of this this asian mafia
right so you can largely consider to be
like a triad and they all like all the
different heads the i guess
the captains of this gang all kind of
organize into a single location
and then out of nowhere you have big
head who just comes riding in on like a
metal horse
do you like like dawn like a knight he's
like what ho the elder order of the
black dragons doth
sup on this eve me thinks an occasion to
slay the lot of them is at hand
what do you think and literally
dawn's like he just like fabricates out
of nowhere a crossbow with poison arrows
and just shoots these guys up
and that's kind of the crazy thing
because then you switch over to kathy
now of course kathy for those of you
guys who are kind of just joining us
here kathy was the
the well their relationship was kind of
falling apart but she was the romantic
interest of stanley ipkis and so the
whole thing behind this is that once
stanley donned the mask
it changed his personality and then
kathy started realizing what was going
on and so on and so forth but basically
she knows the nature of the mask not
only that after the events of the
original mask
story where stanley ipkis was killed by
kathy because of how insane he'd gone
she handed the mask over to callaway
which is how kelloway had it at the
moment when this or really over the
course of the last story and
the beginning of this one and so with
the two of them being familiar with each
other not necessarily lovers or even
friends
ultimately she kind of visits him and
it's just like man like i knew this was
going to end up with something like this
right like i knew that something like
this was going to happen
everybody like anybody who who knows
about the mask is going to gun for the
mask right and just and
the fact that he had it and did the
things he did and drew down a lot of
heat from the mafia we knew that was
gonna happen
right so in a lot of ways she feels a
kind of personal responsibility for all
this stuff going on now one of the
things is that lionel while he is aware
of the concept of big head doesn't
full-on know
exactly how it works and one of these
things is kathy's kind of like okay this
is all my fault right if i hadn't given
him the big head mask none of this would
have happened
and lionel's kinda like wait what what
are you talking about like hold on like
tell me what's going on and then she's
like no and she basically ends up
leaving and so at that point you end up
having uh having kathy who basically
disguises herself as a hooker and then
goes to meet big head and it's one of
these things where she's kind of like
you know my name's kathy and like you
know let's let's go to a place that's a
little more
private right you know places a little
more quiet and so of course big head is
kind of trying to trying to put the
moves
on kathy and then suddenly they're met
by like another mob boss and so like
this guy
literally just guns out right i mean
it's like it's like the shootout at the
okay corral these guys are just
here with guns out in the open and we're
not even talking about like pistols that
are hidden in their coats i mean we're
talking about shotguns
right like mac 10s like ar-15s just
all kinds of weapons right and it's just
like this is going down right like this
is gonna happen and so it's one of these
things where he's like he calls out big
head and he's like get out here right
and one of these guys are like do you
really think it's a good idea for us to
literally like
just initiate a giant fire fight in the
middle and then like broad daylight
downtown in the middle of this city and
the guys like he killed my brother man i
don't really care about the rules
besides i know some guys in the precinct
that can kind of make this go away right
so it's kind of like okay you know
big head comes out of nowhere with a
baseball and literally just like smashes
this guy with it
and then like a few other guys impales
them and kills them then he turns into a
to a football player
runs over the rest of the guys and kills
them and is just like done right kathy's
watching this whole thing go down and
she's like holy cow like this is kind of
nuts and so big heads just like did you
see it right did you see me take all
these guys out like how cool is that man
like i'm
i'm i'm amazing like i'm absolutely
impressive now you know from there
one of his guys kind of hits him up and
says okay look like we literally just
took out a mob boss
and his entire his entire like entourage
in broad daylight outside of our base of
operations look boss
we should probably lay low right we
should probably go somewhere else for a
little while
and so this basically leads to him
grabbing kathy and being like okay cool
yeah let's go ahead and and do our thing
now from there you've got you've got don
muzzo who basically ends up contacting a
parole board chairman
and essentially gets walter freed from
from prison and the whole idea behind
this is to kind of bring walter
directly into the employ of don mozar
brothers this can be done to basically
get get rid of big head right so that
that part's pretty pretty
straightforward not a whole lot going
there as far as kathy and big head go
this is a cool moment because when big
head starts getting undressed right
under under the idea that he's gonna be
touching some naughty bits then like
literally she's like you should just
take the whole thing off right like i
don't know if i want to get with you
like when you're wearing that mask and
it's one of these funny things right
because this guy is obviously like
totally whipped because he's just like
well i mean i don't want to take it off
she's like well if you're not going to
take it off you're not going to get any
action now any reasonable guy would be
like okay well then bye and like like
kick her out right because it's like
what i can do with this mask is
certainly more
certainly better than getting laid by
you but you know because of the nature
of the story uh he's kind of like okay
fine i'll take the mask off right and
then ultimately
uh kathy just like comes out with a gun
and it's just like like literally takes
the mask from this guy
and then kills him right like just like
shoots this guy done so right and then
from there like runs into the attic
right where she's trying to hide from
the rest of these guys they end up
descending on her and then kathy dawns
the mask and shoots them all from below
with like these guns that she's she's
materialized out of nowhere this is when
we get into the actual origin portion
of the mask itself and again there's not
a whole lot doing here right it's just
kind of some measure of a bit of an
origin all we really know
is that somewhere along the line the
mask was used by what appeared to be a
a tribal group and it was almost kind of
like a shaman
but basically what is more or less kind
of like this religious or political
leader of this uh of this tribal group
now the idea is that out of nowhere
somebody like decapitates this guy and
presumably it's part of the ceremony
right kind of like to demonstrate the
power of the mask or maybe some kind of
religious ceremony we're not really
given any context here it's literally
just a series of pictures but the guy
picks the head up and puts it back on
right and so from there it's kind of
like you know the like this is kind of
our god more or less like a like a
celebration of religion essentially is
what it looks like but the guy takes the
mask off and then sits it down and then
the mask is taken and replaced with a
fake
only for us to find out that it's
actually a guy named mitch who stole
this mask now mitch seems to be a guy
who was kind of contracted by some
random mob boss out there the
significance of this this mob boss
doesn't really seem to matter but the
mob boss sent a few henchmen to follow
mitch to make sure that he actually did
the job
and didn't steal the mask and it seems
to be that like rumors of this masked
capabilities have somehow made it out
into the world
but one of the guys basically ends up
asking for the mask which in turn
and of course you know this guy mitch
hands it over uh they in turn go to kill
mitch only for him to find out that
mitch gave him a fake mask and then
mitch puts on the real mask and then
like kills all these guys in just like
some crazy bloody rage and then kathy
wakes up and a lot of this seems to be a
vision that was given to her
by the mask and in this story that's it
that's all we get right that's that's
the extension of the origin of the mask
right that's where it ends and that's as
far back as it goes and even kathy kind
of you know the way she states it here
she's like i mean who really cares if
it's the origin or not right i don't
care enough about this mask to explore
its history in reality i don't even
really want to wear this thing right
this thing is just exceedingly dangerous
i kind of just want to get rid of it if
i possibly can and so switch over to don
mozzo basically meeting with
walter and walter you know just kind of
you know it's kind of like yeah like
basically i'll do this for you a lot of
it's based on a personal vendetta right
because walter's previous employer was
basically killed by big head and so a
lot of it's kind of like i just want to
get this guy
right get the guy who killed my boss
more or less or former boss anyway and
so then you have this hit that's
orchestrated by don mozzo
to take out this eatery and then in turn
kathy who's there at the time gets
pissed
off now the whole point behind this this
hit to fire this rocket was to basically
get the attention a big hit which they
did
kathy grabs one of the henchmen and then
forces this guy to take her uh take her
to where don mozza's operating out of
and then like all hell pops off right
like kathy just comes rolling in and i
mean when she go she comes rolling in
just guns blazing right like this guy
gets dropped through the
through the roof this guy and then and
then in turn like the mob boss starts
begging for his life and then she's like
it's almost not even worth it to kill
you
almost right and then like she goes to
kill this guy only to get shot through
the chest by walter and then people are
just like holy cow like walter killed
big head like this is kind of nuts now
while all that's going on keloway
basically wakes up from his coma right
and so they can throw a little bit of a
celebration for him but one of the
things that happens is that while while
lionel is talking to callaway he
basically kind of alludes to the idea
that kathy is is you know quote unquote
fixing this situation right the last he
heard of her right she's gonna go and
fix it and that's when kelloway puts two
and two together and realizes oh my god
kathy's taking the mask she's gonna go
take out the guys who attacked me
okay we gotta do something about this
right because either she's gonna get
herself killed
or she's gonna succumb to the power of
the mask right so come to the power of
bighead and so again like because of the
fact that bighead is basically
invulnerable one of the things that's
kind of given to us here and we don't
really know if it's the result of
kathy's inexperience or the limitations
of the mask but essentially when she
gets shot she kind of gets knocked out
right she's she's out for a little bit
now a lot of this really seems to be
because of the of her inexperience with
it because we've seen big head just like
shot to pieces with like automatic
rifles we've seen like an entire group
of cops
right like 10 or better shooting him up
and nothing happening at all right so it
looks like it's more a result of her
as opposed to the mask and that a person
who's been using it long enough would
almost really become a god-like
character because of those things she in
turn
goes after walter right now walter being
some kind of a buffoon here is using an
elephant gun which i don't necessarily
blame him right
it looks like he's using slugs because
there's a giant hole he's not using
buckshot and it's not the worst decision
ever because you can do a lot of damage
with an elephant gun but when you're
talking about somebody like big head
honestly i probably would have packed
something a little with a little more
a little more ammo in it right something
with some equivalent firepower and a
little more a little more ammo behind it
right i mean when you literally have to
unload replace your two shots and reload
again it really slows things down but
for walter
it doesn't really matter because in the
time when she basically materializes a
gun and fires at him he just grabs like
a two by four and just starts beating
her over the head
and then she takes off and again it's
one of these things where she's kind of
like i'd like you know i can't take any
more of wearing this match right i can't
take the insanity i can't take the
desire that it instills in me to just
like kill and destroy as many things as
i can
it's literally like a fight over her own
morality right like one part of her
which has the mask is just like we can
do anything we can conquer the world if
we want to and then another part of her
is just like but i don't want to though
right so
this is what happens when bad meets evil
right to quote the the eminem song from
from back in the day and so it's kind of
nuts because from there like she she
kind of distracts walter for a second
and then goes to take off and then of
course walter tracks her down she ends
up putting the mask back on because she
comes with this realization walter's
never gonna stop hunting her and so the
only way for for this to end is for
for her to take out walter and it just
doesn't work right like no matter what
happens because of just how insanely
durable walter is
and the fact that she just doesn't
really have the time to like plan
anything ultimately she can't really get
the upper hand on him now the truth
about this is that it's also kind of
part and parcel to the story i mean this
is the mask he can kind of just you know
big head can just materialize seemingly
anything out of out of nowhere and so
for those of you guys who are asking the
question why doesn't big head just
materialize a bomb and then detonate it
blow up all the docks the entirety of
the docks and kill walter i don't know
the answer to that question right like
we're not getting that just for the sake
of the story being told but it's kind of
cool
right to see this where like essentially
big head meets a person who seems to
more or less be on the same level of
durability or at least lack pain
receptors in the same way big head does
but then suddenly you start to see kathy
giving in to the power of the mask right
her inhibitions kind of dropping off
here and it's kind of one of these
things where it's like you know a couple
of minutes ago that probably would have
just like jingled my nerves a tad and i
would have taken off the mask and
probably given up but not anymore
right like matter of fact i kind of like
it and she just like makes a
flamethrower out of nowhere and just
starts chasing this guy
up and down the docks with a
flamethrower in her hand just torching
this guy and then eventually like with
the whole place burning down around them
she's like you know what enough is
enough right like call in a ceasefire
i apparently can't kill you you cannot
kill me so like
we're calling it a day right we're
basically done here right like there's
the mask she just throws the thing in
front of him and she's like if you want
it
take it right i don't really care now
before walter can do anything you have
callaway who comes flying in to the
docks with a car right smashes walter
into all these tanks jumps out and like
walter goes flying through the wall
and into the lake and like the whole
place explodes so we don't really know
the fate of walter it basically looks
like he essentially died and then
following that it's like
we're done and so what we're kind of
given here is this depiction that the
mask is just sinking down to the bottom
of the water that walter more or less
appears to be dead and like that's it
funny thing there's still a third volume
coming out so the next video that we do
the question you gotta ask yourself is
who gets the mask
and what happens from it all so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob corps if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
you